[Musique]
certains d'entre vous s'étonnent du fait
que les républicains n'est pas voté la
motion de censure hier à l'Assemblée
nationale notre position s'explique à la
fois par un souci de cohérence et aussi
par notre sens des responsabilités nous
condamnons sans ambiguïté la politique
conduite par le gouvernement
c'est-à-dire par Emmanuel Macron
lui-même serions-nous responsable si
nous ajoutions le chaos aux multiples
crisques connaît notre pays crise
politique crise sociale crise budgétaire
crise économique crise de l'école crise
de l'autorité on voit bien que le pays
est dans une situation très difficile
qu'apporterait une motion de censure si
ce n'est ajouté le chaos à toutes ces
difficultés qu'y a-t-il de cohérent
entre
fasciste de la nupes et les démagogues
du rassemblement national nous n'avons
pas voulu joindre nos voix ou la cette
alliance totalement contre nature du
rassemblement national et de la nuesse
ne vise qu'à un seul objectif détruire
les républicains car nous sommes la
seule opposition qui fait preuve d'un
sens des responsabilités l'opposition
oui la chirurgie non ce n'est pas le
gouvernement que les extrêmes veulent
faire tomber mais bien la Cinquième
République